[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous très
heureuse de vous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle saison de Savoie regarde
l'émission de la rédaction de la chaîne
parlementaire ce soir on va parler du
retour fracassant de la réforme des
retraites c'est le dossier sensible de
la semaine on devrait savoir dans les
prochains jours si le gouvernement
décide ou non de passer en force à
l'Assemblée nationale Paris sociale et
Paris politique risqués pour une réforme
qui doit s'appliquer à dès 2003 Paris
justifiés ou pas c'est notre débat ce
soir et si tout dérape ou irez-vous qui
ne ce n'est pas posé cette question à
l'heure où les populistes gagnent du
terrain partout dans le monde notre
grand témoin ce soir il répond dans un
roman trouver refuge ou l'histoire d'un
trio familial qui fuit en Grèce dans le
mont Atos la trityrannie d'un président
réactionnaire élu en 2027 Christophe
honneaudibio signe ce récit aux allures
prémonitoires chez Gallimard nous en
parlerons avec lui enfin on ne change
pas une équipe qui gagne on retrouve
bien sûr enfin des missions nos
affranchis pour leur parti pris avec un
nouveau visage ce soir la féministe Léa
sent bon celle qui va revenir sur
l'affaire Catena Jean-Rémy Baudot lui
s'attardera sur le malaise au sein de la
nupes sur les violences conjugales enfin
Vincent Hugo nous parlera de cette super
star russe qui se dresse contre Poutine
voilà pour le menu c'est parti
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs ravis de vous retrouver
l'heure de vérité du macronisme a sonné
sur les retraites cette phrase n'est pas
de moi mais de vous Guillaume tabard
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous c'est
d'ailleurs le titre de votre édito du
week-end dans le Figaro le chef de
l'État qui veut aller vite et fort
écrivez-vous malgré les risques de
passage en force parce qu'après il sera
trop tard dites-vous et qu'il en va de
la survie de son élan réformateur on y
reviendra bonsoir violette spielbaux
bonsoir et bienvenue sur ce plateau
porte-parole du groupe René sens le
parti présidentiel député du Nord s'il
exécutif décidait de déposer ce fameux
amendement sur le financement des
retraites dans le budget de la Sécurité
sociale et bien vous le défendrez vous
nous direz pourquoi contrairement à vous
Sébastien jumelles bonsoir et bienvenue
sur ce plateau député communiste de
Seine-Maritime membre de la nupes vous
êtes évidemment au style à la fois à
cette réforme sur le fond mais aussi sur
la forme enfin Marc Vignaud journaliste
économique au point qui a tout suivi des
toutes récentes consultations rue de
Grenelle avec le ministre du Travail
consultation des syndicats à nous
rejoindre dans un tout petit instant
mais on commence comme chaque soir avec
la mise Stéphane blackovski bonsoir
bonsoir Myriam bonsoir à tous j'espère
que vous êtes en pleine forme parce que
vous vous êtes mis ce soir dans la tête
d'Emmanuel Macron si j'ai bien compris
c'est à vous tout de suite
[Musique]
alors si j'ai bien compris ce soir
Stéphane si j'ai bien compris ce qui se
passe donc dans la tête d'Emmanuel
Macron le président de la République n'a
pas digéré le grand échec de son premier
mandat en l'occurrence l'abandon de la
réforme des retraites or vous savez que
lorsqu'on tombe de cheval que faut-il
faire le plus vite possible remonter
dessus parce que sinon on commence à
douter puisque on commence à goûter
après on ose plus monter sur le cheval
donc son objectif c'est donc de remonter
en selle le plus vite possible en
faisant voter le plus vite possible une
nouvelle
des retraites alors comment tu
permettras de galoper l'esprit libre
faire de nouvelles réformes
alors vous savez que quand on a une
majorité qui n'est que relative tout est
plus compliqué heureusement il existe le
49-3 mais il y a un problème avec la
49-3 c'est que on peut l'utiliser quand
on est le gouvernement qu'une seule fois
par an donc sur le gris pour la réforme
des retraites est-ce qu'on pourra
l'utiliser pour d'autres réformes en
fait il y a une petite astuce c'est que
ce9.3 on peut l'utiliser autant qu'on
veut quand il s'agit d'une loi
budgétaire donc là par exemple il y a
une loi sur le budget de la Sécurité
sociale qui se présente bientôt donc si
on ajoute un amendement sur la durée des
retraites et bien on pourra la faire
passer même avec un 49,3 sans griller la
cartouche sur le report de l'âge légal
on va y revenir
une autre réforme qui vient de risque il
est important il est d'abord de braquer
les syndicats et puis l'opposition
de toute façon les manifestations sont
déjà prévues mi-octobre grosse
manifestation Mélenchon la gauche au
départ s'il sera contre la vie chère si
c'est contre la réforme des retraites
est-ce que ça va vraiment changer les
choses pour le gouvernement c'est pas
sûr il y a peut-être un risque de devoir
affronter une motion de censure imagine
que la nupesse serait tenté de dépenser
de déposer cette notions et puis Marine
Le Pen a dit que elle était prête à la
voter c'était ce matin sur France Inter
s'il fait passer la réforme des
retraites au travers du PLFSS
c'est-à-dire au travers d'un amendement
en réalité sans qu'il y ait un vrai
projet de loi qui soit débattu à
l'Assemblée nationale mais s'il le fait
il faut qu'il prendra le risque d'une
motion de censure
on sent pas la grosse motivation de la
part de Martin c'est vrai si on
additionne les voies de la nupette et
les voies du RN ça suffit pas pour faire
une majorité et renverser le
gouvernement donc c'est peut-être pour
ça que les patients enthousiaste le
risque aussi et il est peut-être plus
embêtant c'est de se fâcher
définitivement avec lambertger être
ronde assez beauté peut-être plus
embêtant parce que quand même Laurent
Berger pour cette rentrée il avait quand
même été très sympa très gentil il a
accepté de participer au conseil
national de la rénovation qui est censée
refondation oh ça y est je me suis
trompé refondation donc vous voyez le
terme n'est pas encore rentré dans
toutes les têtes mais c'est cet
organisme qui est censé rien souffler la
nouvelle méthode Macron dialogue
compromis conciliation donc forcément
Laurent Berger vous lui dites finalement
on va peut-être glisser un petit
amendement qu'on va voter à 49-3 là
c'est pas exactement ce qu'on lui avait
vendu c'est pas non plus ça conscription
du dialogue social on écoute
je vous le dis il y a un amendement sur
le pffs sur les retraites la CFDT de
facto elle sort du CNR et des
discussions sur ce sujet là surtout les
sujets parce que il ne peut pas y avoir
de la part du président de la République
qui sait faire réélire face à une
candidat d'extrême droite avec des
acteurs qui ont pris leur responsabilité
entre les deux tours pour dire qu'il
fallait pas que ce soit le rassemblement
national qui gouverne ce pays et leur
marché sur la gueule excusez-moi
l'expression quelques mois après marcher
sur la gueule ça Laurent Berger faut
vraiment qu'il soit remonter pour dire
on sent qu'il est vraiment très en
colère et en plus c'est pas le seul être
bien remonté à ruer dans les brancards
c'est aussi le cas au sein de la
majorité de résidentiel regardez
dimanche le président Macron je mets
maintenant sa tête il ouvre le Parisien
même pas besoin de l'ouvrir regardez à
la Une qu'est-ce qu'il voit son Fidel
allié François Barouk Bayrou qui lui
balance un pavé dans la mare en disant
ah non non moi non plus je veux pas
passer en force sur les retraites il
faut le comprendre byru son nouveau rôle
c'est d'être justement le patron de ce
fameux CNR donc d'être l'artisan du
dialogue de la nouvelle méthode de
Macron donc est-ce qu'il prend son rôle
très au sérieux oui est-ce qu'il le
prend trop au sérieux
peut-être selon Olivier Véran
de la question des retraites est mise à
part du CNR n'est pas l'alpha et l'oméga
de toute la politique menée dans notre
nation voilà c'est en 5 secondes qu'on
règle le Caballero faudrait pas de
pattes commencer à une exagérer alors
quels sont ces alliés sur qui peut-il
s'appuyer le président Macron
qui trouvait que son projet de réforme
universel par point était très
intelligente mais beaucoup trop
compliqué quelqu'un qui est prêt à
reculer l'âge de la retraite jusqu'à 65
ans même jusqu'à 67 ans oui qui je veux
dire ça commence par 12 ça finit par do
c'est doudou on l'écoute madame la
Première ministre je vais vous dire les
choses simplement nous serons derrière
vous pour améliorer notre système de
retraite dans le sens de plus de justice
et de plus de travail que vous
choisissiez de le faire en octobre en
décembre en mars quand vous vous
voyez il peut compter sur le droit
Philippe le président qui en avait
jamais douté évidemment ils le savait
qu'il pouvait compter sur sur Edouard
Philippe ça serait peut-être plus
pratique pour lui si vous décompter
plutôt sur les républicains parce
qu'effectivement là si on additionne
l'ensemble des groupes de la majorité
plus les républicains on a une majorité
pour voter mais n'importe quelle loi
sans passer par 49-3 bon sauf que le
modem ne veut pas voter cette amende
donc ça se complique pas mal là je pense
qu'il faut un débat et c'est pour ça que
je vais vous laisser débattre merci
beaucoup merci Stéphane pour pour votre
billet pour votre regard dans Ça vous
regarde comme chaque soir on va
commencer par l'aspect plus politique de
ce dossier très sensible violette pile
bout la méthode
vous êtes prêt à l'affronter cette
tempête politique et sociale si le
gouvernement décidait de dégainer cet
amendement ou pas je pense que quand on
a promis quelque chose aux Français et
c'était le cas dans la campagne
présidentielle on a porté un programme
autour d'Emmanuel Macron qui est un
programme de réformes et de
changement profond du système de
retraite en France pour assurer son
équilibre
à un moment de décider ça fait des
années qu'il y a du diagnostic sur
l'équilibre des retraites qui ne sera
pas assurée pour l'avenir de nos enfants
ça fait des années qu'il y a des
constats partagés on a eu beaucoup de
débats ça s'est stoppé avec le covid
donc à un moment oui il faut avoir le
courage de décider c'est à dire ne
souhaite pas forcément le 20 octobre
quand le texte arrive vous votez
et on a eu un débat très intéressant
parce que les députés sont inquiets sur
sur leur territoire nous on est sur nos
circonscriptions on entend aussi à cette
inquiétude de blocage de manifestation
dans la rue ce qu'on a dit c'est qu'on
serait prêt au moment où le gouvernement
aura décidé de passer la réforme des
retraites donc si c'est pendant le PLFSS
nous serons prêts si c'est au printemps
pour être prêt à la mise en oeuvre qui
commencera à l'été 2023 nous serons
prêts aussi donc c'est ce que vous dites
à votre allié François Bayrou qui vous
dit attention vous allez bloquer le pays
nous on sera prêt on vote tant pis 49-3
on y va ce qu'on dit à François Bayrou
c'est que on l'écoute on a du respect
pour François Bayrou il a exprimé sa
position il a une inquiétude sur la
méthode il voudrait qu'on ralentisse un
petit peu il y a des débats en ce moment
donc il y a rien qui a arrêté sur la
méthode on a entendu Laurent Berger
voilà il faut que on se mette d'accord
puisque on a cette méthode du compromis
pour la passer au meilleur moment mais
on sait que tout le monde ne sera pas
d'accord qu'il y a des oppositions
frontales et qui ne changeront pas donc
c'est à nous à un moment d'avoir le
courage politique
on a pu être surpris de cette option ça
n'est qu'une option on va voir ce qui
est le gouvernement va décider dans les
prochains jours pour vous c'est la pire
des options
le contexte la méthode et le fond le
contexte c'est l'état de crise
économique sans précédent laquelle les
Français sont confrontés le pouvoir
d'achat est en berne d'électricité fait
mal au vide les entreprises des
industries sont fragilisées par cette
dérégulation et la guerre en Ukraine me
semble-t-il est faite pour durer et dans
ce contexte extrêmement préoccupant pour
les Français voilà un président de la
République qui fait comme si il pouvait
remonter à cheval et que la reine autour
était la même sauf qu'il ne vous a pas
échappé que le Parlement sorti des urnes
n'est plus tout à fait le Parlement
solivo l'armée de Playmobil prêt à
mettre en oeuvre les réformes j'allais
dire des yeux fermés mais qu'on a
désormais un parlement qui souhaite
débattre des sujets prendre le temps de
le faire et donc la méthode les
conditions de cet acte d'autorité ne
sont pas réunis
l'opposition il reste opposée le front
syndical et sans ambiguïté y compris
avec la CFDT qui est sur ce sujet très
clair et même les alliés de la majorité
vacille parce que on nous raconte la
réunion de groupe mais moi je sais que
le groupe
majoritaire n'est plus aussi solides et
solidaires qu'avant et qu'en tout cas
les amis de François Bayrou ont sonné
l'armée puis ensuite
l'adoption sans vote comme ça c'est plus
un problème
et le fond c'est que
80% des Français 70% au moins des
Français restent opposés à une réforme
des retraites qui est profondément
injuste parce que nous n'avons pas tous
les mêmes points de vie aux bonnes santé
et que reprendre j'allais dire un slogan
de la CGT en 1910 c'est une retraite
pour les morts c'est à dire que allongé
la durée de cotisation c'est ne pas
prendre en compte que ceux qui souffrent
la France qui manque n'a pas la même
espérance de vie vous ne sentez que ceux
qui font de l'argent en dormant le décor
est planté si je puis dire bonsoir Marc
Vignaud et merci d'être là vous suivez
attentivement ce dossier des retraites
pour pour le point vous êtes journaliste
à la fois politique et économique je
dirais levée de bouclier politique levé
de bouclier syndical comment se sont
déroulés les premières discussions hier
au ministère du Travail et bien Olivier
du stop a fait une présentation
PowerPoint pour montrer à quel point le
régime de retraite avait un déficit dans
les 25 prochaines années c'est c'est à
la fois pas totalement nouveau mais en
même temps le Conseil d'orientation des
retraites et bien obligé de reconnaître
que pendant 25 ans en moyenne on va
avoir un déficit du régime revenu donc
il va falloir l'équilibrer donc le
ministre il a il a fait cette
présentation et après il a répondu un
peu aux objectifs aux objections des des
syndicats qui sont prêts à rompre toutes
les relations avec le gouvernement sur
tous les dossiers si le gouvernement
passe en force oui oui apparemment
Laurent Berger a dit je quitterai le
Conseil national de la refondation si
jamais
le Medef Geoffroy de roubaisieux
manifestement n'est pas pour cette
méthode non plus alors il faut nuancer
le patronat ils veulent pas que tout le
monde soit dans la rue ils disent qu'il
faut un minimum de concertation ils
veulent qu'il y a un peu de cogestion
dans la on a ce qu'on appelle une
concertation et non pas une négociation
entre partenaires sociaux donc ils
aimeraient qu'on prenne un peu plus de
temps mais pendant très longtemps le
Medef a plaidé pour repousser l'âge
mais pas sur le 49 ans tout de suite il
pousse pas à ce qu'il y a 49,3 ils sont
pas non plus très opposés il faut voir
quel paramètre déjà seront retenus pour
vous pour bien comprendre là je
m'adresse aussi à Guillaume tabac cette
méthode ce passage en force c'est plutôt
habile ou c'est carrément kamikaze
écouter je pense qu'il faut savoir que
dans le débat politique
les querelles autour des méthodes sert
souvent de prétexte prenons le cas de
cette réforme des retraites mondiales
mais là il passe en en force donc il y
aura pas de discussion il y aura pas
d'innocation et il prend le risque que
ça provoque des manifestations et donc
des blocages la réforme qui a été
interrompue par la crise du covid elle
avait été précédée par plus d'un an plus
d'un an de concertation menée c'est à
l'époque par par Jean-Paul Delevoye il
avait reçu tout le monde des heures des
heures tous les syndicats étaient reçus
pendant des heures ce travail de
concertation avait été fait et ce que ça
empêchait qui est des grèves notamment
dans le transport public des
manifestations de rue réunissant des
plusieurs centaines du milliers de
personnes évidemment non les réformes de
retraite dans votre lancement vous
évoquez de manière subliminale la
réforme de 2003 est-ce qu'elle doit être
appliquée dès 2023 autant pour moi déjà
à l'époque qui avait été adopté au terme
là aussi de près d'un an de concertation
est-ce qu'il y a pas eu des
manifestations fortes
pas vraiment une révélation pour nous
mais je me permets de rebondir le
discours de la méthode et de la nouvelle
méthode c'est le président de la
République qu'il a impulsé à l'orée de
ce nouveau quinquennat et il a une
sacrée contradiction à gérer il ne peut
pas commencer le mandat mandater sa
première ministre en disant désormais on
a changé on a vu que le Parlement
n'était plus tout à fait le même on va
mettre en place un Conseil national de
la refondation et donc désormais on a
compris que les actes verticaux
abruptent n'étaient pas à une mode de
mode de gouvernance acceptable et et
dans le même temps immédiatement
immédiatement après
poser un acte d'autorité comme celui-ci
deuxièmement moi je pense que la parole
du président a perdu en valeur elle n'a
plus la même valeur que
au début du précédent quinquennat plus
la même valeur auprès de sa majorité
plus la même valeur aux yeux des
Français il n'est pas en situation
toujours plus loin
le Conseil national de la refondation et
même ici même rappelez-vous le discours
de politique générale de d'Elizabeth
borne le mot de compromis qu'elle a
répété moult foie comme une marque de
fabrique c'est pas contradictoire là à
un moment il faut dire la vérité aux
Français sur les retraites on a un
système qui appartient de 2022 sera
déficitaire il faut donc comme la
promune président de la République
Compass cette réforme des retraites
rapidement en début de mandat que ce
soit dans un mois et demi ou deux mois
ou que ce soit dans 6 mois il faut que
ce soit rapide et ça il faut avoir un
discours lucide parce que derrière ça
finalement c'est quoi c'est les valeurs
qu'on défend dans le projet du président
de la République et sa parole elle tient
à ça la solidarité entre les générations
la prospérité du pays pour l'avenir de
nos enfants on ne veut pas une France
qui s'appauvrisse et quand on a Jean-Luc
Mélenchon la nups qui propose des
retraites à temps en temps et bien
Jean-Luc Mélenchon il a un programme qui
n'est pas financé qui a un déficit de
200 milliards d'euros et donc entre nous
c'est un acte de responsabilité et loin
avant de voir ce petit sujet sur les
conclusions du corps peut-être aussi
qu'il y a l'hiver social qui arrive
toutes les capitales européennes
craignent un hiver de mécontentement au
fond est-ce que cette réforme si le
gouvernement la femme maintenant il ne
la fera plus jamais
du point de vue des macronistes
évidemment c'est un argument parce que
est-ce que la situation sera meilleure
en janvier en février quand ils vont
laisser le prix du gaz et de
l'électricité augmenter de 15%. et à ce
moment-là qu'est-ce que avec qui va
négocier avec Laurent Berger qui lui dit
ce week-end moi ma solution pour
équilibrer le régime de retraite c'est
augmenter la flat tax c'est revenir sur
la taxation égale du travail et du
capital donc revenir sur un des symboles
du macronisme donc en fait il y a très
peu de négociations qui qui peut
s'ouvrir est-ce que Laurent Berger est
prêt à avancer sur la durée de
cotisation on ne sait même pas pas un
ballon d'essai ça ressemble à une
manœuvre assumée pour arriver à vos fins
alors on va aller sur le fond de la
réforme tout de même y compris sur la
réalité du système des retraites ça pas
du tout si c'était si c'était un ballon
d'essai ce serait une bonne stratégie
aussi dire regardez moi ça fait
longtemps que je promets cette réforme
je suis réformateur je veux y aller bon
je suis un peu bloqué par par le pays
etc et puis finalement j'accorde
magnanime cette concertation réclamée
par la CFDT et bah il va falloir que la
CFDT prennent ses responsabilités
un grand projet de loi travail où on
pourrait mettre les républicains dans la
boucle l'année prochaine et dire qu'on
ferait la réforme avec effectivement un
peu plus concerté parce qu'il y a des
mécanismes compliqué
à négocier
ce qui intéresse les Français sur la
motion de censure on entendait Marine Le
Pen elle l'avait j'imagine que la nuit
pèse aussi est-ce que
on déposera bien sûr la déposera
évidemment la votre vous pensez que la
républicains qui sont en plein congrès
et là ça change tout pour évoquer faire
tomber le gouvernement non ils l'ont
déjà dit
publiquement ou en privé en tout cas
même même ceux qui sont sur une ligne
dure d'opposition Emmanuel Macron disent
clairement qui n'est pas question de
votre pour eux de voter une motion de
censure qui serait déposée ou par la
Nupe par un des groupes de la nuque ou
par
nationale envie de déposer leurs propres
émotion là où il y aura un risque
peut-être pour gouvernement c'est si LR
décidé de déposer une motion de censure
que les éventuels groupes de gauche et
du rassemblement national pour évoquer
mais on voit bien clairement que c'est
pas LR qui m'est presque défi Emmanuel
Macron aurait fermé les retraites qui va
censurer si l'aventure il va au bout de
7 ans
avant de nous dire au fond qu'est-ce
qu'il pourrait y avoir dans cet
amendement est-ce qu'on reporte l'âge
légal 63 64 est-ce qu'on allonge la
durée de cotisation à faire quand même
le point sur la situation financ partir
de notre système de retraite avec les
mots mérites
dans ce rapport il y a d'abord un
constat qui peut surprendre le régime
des retraites est aujourd'hui
excédentaire plus 900 millions d'euros
l'an dernier plus 3 milliards 200
millions prévus cette année mais le
Conseil d'orientation des retraites
anticipe un retour au déficit des 2023
quel que soit le scénario testé ce
déficit devrait se creuser
progressivement jusqu'en 2032 avant de
se stabiliser le retour à l'équilibre ne
se ferait pas avant au moins 25 ans
autre indicateur la part des dépenses de
retraite dans le PIB elle devrait rester
globalement stable jusqu'en 2027 autour
de 14%. mais elle augmentera ensuite
jusqu'en 2032 et ce quel que soit les
scénarios les auteurs du rapport
précisent toutefois que les dépenses de
retraite ne sont pas dans une dynamique
non contrôlée mais ils estiment que
l'évolution de ses dépenses n'est pas
compatible avec les objectifs du
programme de stabilité
si le rapport se montre plus pessimiste
que le précédent c'est qu'il s'appuie
sur des hypothèses de gains de
productivité et de chômage moins
favorables mais les auteurs de ce
rapport insistent aussi sur les fortes
incertitudes qui entourent ces travaux
de projection
marvinho on voit bien selon les
conclusions du Conseil d'orientation des
retraites que d'ici 10 ans il va y avoir
un déficit équival va nous cesser de se
creuser donc il y a quand même un
problème à moyen long terme pendant 25
ans 25 ans un déficit et en plus le
corps multiplie quand même des
hypothèses qui sont globalement
favorables en fait il y a un déficit du
système de retraite qui est assez bien
établi et ce qui est ce qui est
intéressant d'ailleurs dans le débat sur
le timing ou sur est-ce qu'on passe par
le plfs ou pas c'est qu'avant même de
savoir quelle mesure va on va la
majorité va intégrer
tout le monde dit bah non on en veut pas
c'est pas pareil si on allonge la durée
de cotisation
de l'âge le report de l'âge légal 63 64
ou alors c'est très difficile à dire
parce que c'est Emmanuel Macron qui
prendra la décision au final le report
de l'âge légal à un avantage c'est que
ça rapporte beaucoup et ça rapporte
rapidement il faut il faut préciser
qu'on parle des générations qui vont
partir à la retraite dans les prochaines
années là il s'agit d'accélérer un petit
peu un recul de l'âge légal qui va se
faire de toute façon parce que des
réformes précédentes sont en train de
monter en charge et donc c'est recul de
l'âge moyen de départ il est en train de
se faire donc la question c'est est-ce
qu'on l'accélère donc on peut
l'accélérer par l'âge de départ donc ça
ça frappe un petit peu ceux qui enfin de
façon plus importante ceux qui ont des
carrières longues donc l'opposition 10
c'est injuste mais ça rapporte beaucoup
et sinon on peut passer par la durée de
cotisation et là ça rallongerait et là
c'est juste parce que
ça rapporte ça rapporte moins et donc il
y a une piste qui à mon avis mais qui va
être exploré et qu'Emmanuel Macron a un
peu suggéré dans différentes
interventions quand on l'écoute bien
c'est de mixer en fait cette durée de
cotisation avec un recul de l'âge légal
qui serait beaucoup moins fort par
exemple à 63 ans ce qui permettrait de
répartir un peu l'effort sur la totalité
de la population et qui permettrait
selon plusieurs économistes qui ont
l'oreille d'Emmanuel Macron de trouver
le même montant d'économie parce que il
faut bien voir que pour mener la
politique budgétaire qui Emmanuel Macron
entend mener d'ici 2027 il faut
absolument faire des économies sur les
retraites je rappelle qu'en Europe on
est parmi les pays qui dépensant le plus
pour les retraites qu'on a parmi les
taux d'emploi des seniors donc des
personnes qui ont entre 55 et 64 ans qui
est le plus faible de toute l'Europe et
donc ça c'est autant de cotisations qui
rentrent dans les caisses pour tous les
systèmes sociaux pas que pour les
retraites des impôts c'est un argument
qui peut vous parler plus plus on
travaille plus on cotise et plus le
modèle social français est solide
900 millions d'euros d'excédents 2021
3,2 milliards en 2022 c'est la réponse
sur est-ce que c'est urgent deuxièmement
personne ne conteste les prospectives
même si les scénaries du corps sont
pessimistes sur la dégradation du
financement des retraites mais donc à
financement égale nous avons des
propositions très claires à formulaire
pour les exonérations de cotisations
sociales par exemple c'est 70 milliards
d'exonérations depuis le début du
quinquennat précédent on voit bien que
si on
voit bien on agit sur ce levier là on a
des modalités de financement nouvelle si
on agit sur l'égalité professionnelle
homme femme on a en matière de recettes
et de cotisations des recettes
supplémentaires si on agit sur des
salaires
idem enfin moi je veux dire j'ai trois
interlocuteurs qui semblent impatients
de voir cette réforme mise en œuvre plus
ou moins mais très impatient tout de
même mais c'est pas des chiffres
derrière ça il y a des hommes et des
femmes moi j'ai en tête moi j'ai en tête
les verriers au bouchot chez moi les
gouttiers qui a une durée de vie de 15
ans de moins que tous ceux qui sont
autour de la table les Atsems qui à 55
ans ont la vie et le dos broyé tous ceux
qui ont qui savent qui peuvent mourir
avant de prétendre à la retraite cela
cela les chiffres votre impatience
révolutionnaire votre volonté de faire
allégeance au plan de stérilité européen
parce que c'est de ça
et il pense à leur vie tout de suite on
trouver de l'argent ailleurs c'est ce
que nous dit Sébastien jumelles et
surtout la pénibilité qu'est-ce que
dire à ceux qui nous regardent sur cette
réforme juste parce que vous allez faire
probablement un amendement purement
financier mais il y a énormément de
d'attentes sur la pénibilité sur les
carrières longues sur la question de
l'emploi des seniors qu'est-ce que vous
répondez à ça déjà je réponds quand
j'entends monsieur expliquer la
pénibilité de certaines carrière et de
certains métiers j'entends la même chose
que lui sur ma circonscription donc là
dessus je vous rassure que ce soit
Emmanuel Macron que ce soit les députés
de l'ensemble des groupes je pense
entendre la même chose et sont
conscients
d'adaptations sur les carrières qui sont
hachées
la différence entre les femmes et les
hommes les métiers qui sont les plus
pénibles moi j'ai travaillé la SNCF on
va pas avoir les mêmes conditions de
retraite pour quelqu'un comme moi qui
était DRH dans un bureau et quelqu'un
qui répare les voix en heure de nuit
donc et accroupi à genoux sur une voie
ou un rail donc
ça c'est du bon sens et c'est ce qui
réclame l'ensemble des collabondements
pas de réponse
de fondamentale avec la nude avec qui on
débat ce soir et on aura tous ces débats
c'est que
arrêtez l'exonération des cotisations
sociales et bien c'est
70 milliards nous on a une vision du
travail de favoriser le travail pas de
la paresse on a une vision d'accompagner
les entreprises
en défiscalisant un certain nombre
d'activités qui permettent d'accompagner
la croissance et c'est cette croissance
qui permet que les travailleurs cotisent
pour financer les retraites de demain
donc on a une vision très différente
ne comprendraient pas qu'on réforme les
retraites si c'est pour financer autre
chose que leur retraite ou la retraite
de leurs enfants
il y a un malentendu là dessus il y a
Bruxelles un pack de stabilité qui
a-t-on quand même des réformes pour
arriver à résorber les déficits revenir
aux 3% dans 5 ans cette réforme elle va
résorber quoi alors les déficites à
venir des retraites tout simplement les
déficits du quoiqu'il en coûte en
général je pense qu'il faut et ça c'est
peut-être aussi un risque pour Emmanuel
Macron il ne faut pas vendre la même
réforme deux fois
soit on dit que la réforme des retraites
vise à financer les déficits annoncés ce
que qui n’être appelé par le corps
quelqu'un les recettes et encore j'ai
cru comprendre que le report de l'âge
légal
il fallait recettes ne suffirait pas à
compenser intégralement les déficits
donc on peut dire ça servir à ça on ne
peut pas dire en même temps cette
réforme va nous aider à faire la réforme
de l'école de l'hôpital cetera ça c'est
pas vrai aussi trouver des financements
spécifiques mais on peut dire ça va ça
va financer le boucle les tarifaires non
non
il y a conclusion dont il faut se garder
un la première c'est de dire on peut
tout on peut financer plein de choses
grâce à cette réforme non ce ne sera pas
vrai et il y a quelque chose aussi alors
je sais bien que c'est dans le débat
politique moi je suis pas un partenaire
je suis pas dans le débat politique
j'essaye avec un prisme qui le nôtre ça
suit la vision qui portait par Le Figaro
mais pas comme un acteur politique bon
dire ah vous êtes impatient de voir les
reins de retraite c'est comme si vous
vous aviez le monopole de la générosité
qu'on fasse il y aurait des sadiques qui
voudraient punir les salariés bon je
crois l'inverse et je suis surpris je
suis quelqu'un qui porte une tradition
politique comme la vôtre n'est pas le
souci de la solidarité entre les
générations parce que j'étais amené
parce que ne pas faire la réforme des
retraites aujourd'hui ça n'est ça n'est
pas dire on ne veut pas de taxer les
travailleurs aujourd'hui c'est on ne
veut pas que ce soit les générations
futures donc vos enfants et les nôtres
qui est apporté le poids financier
aujourd'hui
l'épouvantail de la paresse ne tient pas
sur ce sujet puisque
et c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
avons des propositions pour bouger des
modalités de financement de ce système
par répartiaux me dit qu'on va continuer
débattre de ce sujet donc ce débat
s'achève cette question au fond de
l'allocation des des économies faites
par l'allongement du de la durée du
travail les Français les Français
peuvent comprendre que finalement ça ne
va pas forcément aller au dessus
imposé par Bruxelles si on veut réduire
le déficit à 3% du PIB en 2027 c'est
parce que on veut que la dette publique
se stabilise on cherche avant tout à
contrôler nos finances il y a une partie
de la dette française qui est détenue
par des investisseurs étrangers et les
investisseurs étrangers quand ils voient
que la dette augmente sans contrôle
qu'il fallait que la que l'économie soit
bonne que l'économie soit mauvaise et
bah il s'inquiète et donc ils ne veulent
plus financer la France on voit que les
taux d'intérêt remontent donc il y a un
moment tout le monde sait même les
économistes de gauche disent un système
de par répartition de retraite ça doit
pas être équilibré amené après année
mais ça ne peut pas supporter des
déficits sur 25 ans surtout quand on
veut financer la transition écologique
surtout quand on veut financer une
amélioration du système éducatif donc il
faut qu'au moins le système soit à peu
près équilibré le problème des
macronistes c'est que effectivement si
on passe par le PLFSS les mesures de
compensation ne pourront pas être
incluses dans le projet de loi
puisqu'elles sont extrêmement complexes
et donc là effectivement il y a un
problème parce que
financière et pas des contreparties mais
encore une fois mais c'est important
les mesures d'âge peuvent être
composées de façon à ce que les mesures
de compensation soient moins importantes
puisque la réforme serait moins violente
et puis on peut promettre dans un autre
texte de loi des mesures de concert de
compensation à concerter sur le plan
politique la hache financière sans les
contreparties il faut pas trop forcer
Sébastien jumelles pour trouver des
formules qui vont marquer l'opinion mais
est-ce que vous êtes prêt à la mener
cette rue de bataille ça va faire un
moment quand on est au PLFSS on est
effectivement sur un exercice budgétaire
comme vous l'avez rappelé donc on parle
des dépenses de la sécurité local et on
agit sur les retraites nous ce qu'on va
rappeler dans l'ensemble du projet qui
est porté par Emmanuel Macron et qu'on
va mettre en oeuvre ici à l'automne
c'est que on veut assurer une traite
digne à toutes les Françaises et les
Français qu'on a un minimum vieillesse
sur lequel on sait engagé une retraite à
1100 euros qui n'est pas encore le cas
aujourd'hui pour tous on veut que les
les personnes puissent prévoir l'avenir
de leurs enfants en avec une meilleure
sérénité parce que aujourd'hui tout le
monde est inquiet sur l'avenir et donc
notre responsabilité c'est de bien gérer
l'ensemble du budget de l'État de
réduire les déficits publics et de
financer des nouveaux programmes pour
l'éducation elle est très bien compris
on va s'arrêter là évidemment on va y
revenir très régulièrement dans Ça vous
regarde sur LCP sur ce dossier très
sensible des retraites fin du suspense
normalement peut-être d'ici lundi
prochain pour la présentation
très importante il y a le comité de
suivi des retraites qui est un autre
organisme que le Conseil d'orientation
des retraites qui donne un avis en
général cet avis et beaucoup plus
catastrophiste que la vie du Conseil
d'orientation des retraites
très très collégiale et donc du coup ça
relancerait la communication
gouvernementale
on lui inocule la rage ses organismes
sont là on fait en tout cas les
organismes créés par François Hollande
sont déjà bien prêtes merci à vous merci
merci pour ce débat on va à présent
accueillir notre grand témoin que vous
connaissez très bien Marc Vigneau
puisqu'il travaille dans votre journal
il est directeur adjoint de la rédaction
du Point mais il est aussi romancier son
dernier livre trouvé refuge chez
Gallimard raconte un monde qui bascule
dans le nationalisme et l'intérêt
tolérance ou irez-vous si tout dérape on
sait tous un peu posé la question et
puis comment résister Christophe phono
di bio nous rejoint tout de suite après
l'invitation qui lui est adressée signée
Marco pommier
si on vous invite Christophe honaudibio
c'est parce que vous ne passez pas
inaperçu en cette rentrée littéraire
avec votre nouveau roman le septième
trouvait refuge je pense qu'on a tous
besoin en ce moment de trouver refuge et
l'un des mérites et l'un des pouvoirs de
la littérature l'un des pouvoirs des
livres c'est de nous offrir aussi le
temps d'une lecture un refuge et dans un
refuge il peut se passer beaucoup de
choses Christophe honneau di bio vous
avez l'écriture dans le sang très jeune
déjà vous alimentiez sur Internet à un
journal intime le journal de l'énerver
une sorte de blog avant l'heure
aujourd'hui journaliste directeur
adjoint de la rédaction du Point mais
aussi écrivain à succès en 2013 ou
décrochez le Grand Prix du roman de
l'Académie française pour votre livre
plongée adapté au cinéma par Mélanie
Laurent
[Musique]
votre actualité c'est donc ce nouveau
roman trouvé refuge l'histoire d'un père
d'une mère et d'une petite fille de 7
ans en cavale fuyant vers un monastère
dans l'un des derniers sanctuaires
d'Europe le mont Atos en Grèce une
famille forcée de quitter la France en
2027 face à un pouvoir devenu
autoritaire à l'Elysée les Français ont
élu un dirigeant populiste réactionnaire
que tout s'appellent papa c'est un
pouvoir d'extrême droite mais qui dit on
n'est pas extrême nous on veut juste le
bon sens le bien des gens c'était assez
dans ce lac c'est une tyrannie douce un
livre ancré dans l'actualité comme une
alerte face à la montée des extrêmes en
Europe Suède Hongrie Pologne Italie
l'extrême droite avance masquée
dites-vous quoi que
je suis une femme je suis une mère je
suis italienne je suis chrétienne alors
Christophe honaudibio à l'heure où le
covid et les QR code ont malmené nos
libertés à l'heure de la surveillance
généralisée en Chine et des attaques
contre les intellectuels comme Salman
Rushdie cette question votre livre
préfigure-t-il la France de 2027 à vous
la parole
bonsoir Christophe
trouver refuge chez Gallimard c'est à la
fois un récit Altan stressant on l'a
compris parce qu'une famille un trio
familial fuit la traque d'un populiste
qui prend le pouvoir dans 5 ans mais
c'est aussi un livre plein d'espoir
parce que c'est lumineux ça raconte la
beauté du monde ça raconte la
transmission entre un père et sa fille
mais d'abord pour répondre à la question
qui vous est adressée se tournant
populiste là qui va nous précipiter dans
un sorte de régime fasciste que vous
décrivez c'est ce qui nous attend oui
national populiste je pense ça ou post
fasciste comme on dit en Italie bah
c'est le mot préfigure-t-il qui est
auquel je veux pas répondre j'espère que
non on écrit toujours pour éloigner le
danger je crois que vous vous l'avez
assez bien dit pour alerter en tout cas
ça fait cinq ans qu'on voit monter enfin
plus de 5 ans d'ailleurs moi j'ai
commencé il y a 5 ans qu'on voit monter
ses forces et avec des mécanismes qu'on
connaît bien maintenant des
diabolisations appel au bon sens
critique des élites critiques de tout ce
qui peut vous enseigner des choses
nombreuses critique de la transmission
critique des lobbies et tout ça fait que
on a vu les premiers résultats en Suède
dimanche
et c'est vrai que je me disais
au fond oui c'est vrai moi j'ai parlé
d'un papa mais c'est une genre jamais
l'ONU au masculin vous êtes très
charismatique totalement des diabolisés
à ses charismatique comme elle l'est
d'ailleurs et on va voir mais non je
souhaite que ça ne soit pas une
prophétie mais néanmoins les forces sont
à l'oeuvre on sent une inquiétude un
avertissement mais au sens aussi la
force de conviction à travers le récit
de cette de cette famille alors pour
planter le décor avant d'en venir à la
Grèce parce que c'est très important de
nous dire pourquoi vous avez choisi cet
endroit là le mot Atos dites nous sans
trop dévoiler des choses ce secret que
détient le père Sacha intellectuel
philosophe médiatique à propos de ce
populiste qu'il connaît depuis sa
jeunesse oui il est comme nous sur un
plateau il gagne sa vie en commentant
l'actualité enfin lui c'est son rôle
c'est un intellectuel qui aurait voulu
écrire un roman qui ne l'a jamais fait
que sa femme pousse à écrire sa femme et
professeur Mina spécialiste de la
Renaissance en lien du tout avec avec le
mouvement macronien voilà la Renaissance
exactement et un jour sur un plateau
télé finalement alors qu'il a décidé de
ne plus soumettre il a cette phrase on
parle de la xénophobie presque
nécessaire de la fermeture nécessaire de
la France
d'un projet européen chrétien et il a
cette phrase papa n'a pas toujours été
comme ça et là le plateau se fige que
dit-il que s'est-il sur le passé de papa
et on va découvrir ça la femme ne le
sait pas d'ailleurs Mina ne le sait pas
il va découvrir ça peu à peu comme la
lectrice comme le lecteur et ce secret
effectivement je vais pas le dévoiler
mais c'est la lecture est-ce qu'on est
les mêmes à 50 ans est-ce qu'on a est-ce
qu'on sait pas trahi par rapport à celui
ou celle qu'on était à 20 ans et surtout
est-ce que on connaît vraiment celui ou
celle qu'on aime comment vous avez
réussi à vous comment dire pas vous
mettre dans la peau mais en tout cas à
décrire ce personnage dans dans une
France qui pourrait être à mi-chemin
entre celle de Trump de chez giping les
réseaux sociaux la surveillance de masse
est très présente sur les téléphones
portables mais aussi ce recours au chef
autoritaire que peut incarner Poutine le
chef en fait c'est des sondages déjà il
y a 8 ans on s'apercevait en France qui
avait une volonté d'avoir un chef le mot
je me souviens d'un homme fort
et généralement quand on écrit ce que je
voulais faire il me fallait en fait
l'arrière-plan politique à cette fuite
et vous l'avez dit à ce champ sur la
beauté du monde et ce qu'on transmet à
nos enfants parce que c'est la question
centrale qu'est-ce qu'on transmet à nos
enfants justement dans un monde qui
devient de plus en plus dur de plus en
plus national populiste de plus en plus
fermée et qui voudrait qu'on soit les
uns et les autres des des loups pour les
uns ou pour les autres et c'est l'idée
au contraire de rester humain et tout
bonnement je suis journaliste vous
l'avez rappelé donc je vois comme vous
au premier loge sur le balcon de
l'actualité des événements et ça me
passionne j'ai été aussi longtemps
journaliste politique et on voit les
forces en présence depuis 2013
Marc des restrictions de liberté c'est
très intéressant parce qu'il y a plein
d'anecdotes on sent qu'on voilà c'est
c'est un peu de l'anticipation ça
pourrait nous arriver je pense par
exemple à ce groupe les semaines
il faut voir que voilà ce nouveau
pouvoir est obsédé par les racines
chrétiennes de de la France et de
l'Europe par la
natalités
donc des fils aussi la poitrine nue mais
avec des enfants à boucher à leurs seins
réclamant au fond une politique
nataliste encourager par le gouvernement
et les raisons c'est vrai que ce livre
aussi vient de ce que j'ai vu d'abord
chez Orban mais de plus en plus proche
de chez nous mais même ce qui s'est
passé je pense que le confinement aussi
a eu l'effet aussi un effet
d'accélérateur sur le fait de vouloir
être protégé de vouloir rester chez soi
je pense que la psychée est aussi
mondiale en tout cas contemporaine a été
aussi modifié par ça oui des médias
aussi est très présent mais cette scène
formidable très cruelle très dur sur un
plateau télévisé du professeur humilié
ça je l'ai vu en Italie en fait pour la
sortie d'un livre précédent ou en Italie
déjà et on le voit aujourd'hui en France
sur les débat télé dès que quelqu'un
savait mieux qu'un autre débatteurs
c'était vous n'êtes pas mon professeur
je ne suis pas votre élève et ça on l'a
entendu on l'a entendu par exemple dans
le débat Darmanin Bardella au moment des
législatives moi je rends mon livre en
janvier honnêtement je pensais pas être
comme ça rattrapé par l'actualité les
choses étaient déjà en germe mais voir à
ce point le triomphe du rassemblement
national derrière le faux triomphe en
fait de la nuque voir la mélodie aux
portes du pouvoir la Suède le fameux
modèle suédois c'était quand même
l'associal démocratie le modèle que tout
le monde brandissait le voir se
retourner à ce point et donc oui je suis
inquiet j'essaie à travers ce roman de
mettre en scène cette inquiétude mais
aussi d'apporter des contre-poisons
je le disais c'est un roman sur sur les
sensations aussi il y a des bains de mer
des bains de soleil il y a énormément de
scènes entre entre le père Sacha et sa
petite fille Irène tout ça se déroule
dans le mont Atos cette presqu'île gérée
par des des moines orthodoxes avec toute
une série de monastères Byzantins
pourquoi là-bas j'ai choisi cet endroit
parce que c'est un endroit que je
connais bien je suis allé dès que j'ai
eu 20 ans j'y suis retourné depuis
jusqu'à y aller avec mon enfant pas pour
des raisons religieuses mais pour des
pour aller voir presque par curiosité
quel était ce monde dans lequel des
hommes avaient choisi de rompre avec
nous on est dans le monde ils appellent
ça le monde le monde donc eux vivent
dans une sorte de contre-monde
d'antimonde c'est une sorte de jardin
d'Eden posé sur la mer le seul point
noir c'est qu'il n'y a c'est interdit
aux femmes et aux enfants et moi
justement j'y emmène une enfant une
toute jeune une toute petite fille parce
que je voulais un peu perturber les les
lois de cet endroit mais c'est un
endroit où ou des gens ont choisi de
vivre contrairement aux messages qu'on
nous professe aujourd'hui ou les
téléphones portables ne passent pas ça
c'était important pour matraque parce
que ce qu'il faut rappeler c'est que ils
sont trois vous l'avez dit l'homme et sa
petite fille se retrouvent sur sûrement
Atos pour se mettre à l'abri et Mina la
femme la professeure de renaissance
de la transmission que vous évoquez qui
est un peu le fil rouge du roman il y a
cette scène où le père au fond face à la
brutalité de ce monde où les où les
libertés n'existent quasiment plus ou la
vérité n'existe plus se demande et si on
élevait bien notre fille et il parle
avec sa mère et il lui dit avec la mère
de sa fille avec sa femme et lui dit et
si on devait pas tout simplement lui
apprendre à dur voilà à baiser le monde
c'est votre expression c'est une
question qu'on se qu'on se pose tous
Comment qu'est-ce qu'on transmet nos
enfants dans ce monde dur où on voit que
le culte de la force revient le culte de
la vérité a disparu face à la poste
vérité comment on fait et une fois qu'il
a dit ça sa femme lui donne presque une
fessée en lui disant mais si tu te renie
si tu ne crois plus en ce que tu en sais
en quoi tu crois alors c'est terminé et
notre fille est condamnée à devenir
comme eux et donc le message du livre
c'est ça c'est comment on reste humain
comment on préserve quand le temps est à
la bourrasque la petite flamme
d'humanité qui est en nous et Irène en
cela la petite fille c'est une petite
fille parce que c'est l'espoir c'est
l'avenir et justement je mise quand même
sur un 2027 plus heureux que ce qui se
passe dans trouver refuge
parce que d'abord on le lâche pas très
sincèrement Christophe
on y croise des moines Byzantins la
Méditerranée des populistes et toute une
série de personnages très cultes vous
restez avec moi c'est l'heure
d'accueillir nos affranchis comme chaque
soir pour leur parti pris ils vont vous
faire réagir un nouveau visage ce soir
les hambontel féministes journalistes
fondatrice du podcast popol Jean Rémi
Baudot de France Info qu'on retrouve
avec plaisir comme chaque mardi et puis
le grand sporteur Vincent hugeeux ce
soir la peur de Poutine battrait-elle en
retraite en Russie nos affranchis les
voici bonsoir les h en Boncelles bonsoir
je suis ravie de vous accueillir dans
cette émission vous allez nous parler ce
soir de la faire catenens mais pas
seulement vous nous dites sur les
violences conjugales ne pas séparer le
politique de l'homme
alors effectivement il me semblait
important de revenir sur cette notion on
l'avait entendu pendant la cérémonie des
Oscars on a eu beaucoup parlé de la
nécessité ou pas d'ailleurs de séparer
l'homme de l'artiste et moi où ce soir
j'ai envie de vous dire il ne faut pas
se séparer l'homme du politique plus
précisément comment peut-on imaginer
qu'un homme qui est auteur de violence
conjugales puisse se prononcer sur un
texte par exemple concernant les
violences faites aux femmes comment
peut-on aussi imaginer qu'un homme qui
est dans ses relations personnelles avec
les femmes et toujours s'inscrit
toujours dans une logique de domination
et de violence et que c'est ce même
homme puisse être à la tête de l'un de
nos principaux mouvements politiques
comment peut-on imaginer par ailleurs
qu'un homme accusé de violence sexuelles
soit à la tête de la police nationale
police qui il faut le rappeler comme le
font régulièrement les associations
féministes ne donnent pas toujours le
meilleur des accueils aux victimes de
violences sexuelles et sexistes donc non
je pense qu'il est important de ne pas
séparer l'homme du politique et ça aussi
pour plusieurs raisons la première aussi
de ces raisons et qu'il est important et
enfin je pense grand temps de prendre
connaissance de prendre conscience de
ces mécanismes d'entraide masculine qui
sont
omniprésentes en fait et qui sont à
l'oeuvre dans les instances de pouvoir
et dans les partis politiques j'imagine
par le premier tweet de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui dans un premier temps n'a
pas eu un mot pour l'épouse d'Adrien
catenin et à soutenu son bras droit oui
bien sûr mais ce n'est pas le premier
malheureusement à faire ça on se
souvient d'autres affaires ou par
exemple Marlène Schiappa avait rappelé
que bien sûr Nicolas Hulot avait toute
la confiance du gouvernement on se
souvient aussi d'Emmanuel Macron qui
disait que encore une fois son ministre
de l'Intérieur avait toute sa confiance
puisque leur relation est une relation
de confiance et la fameuse relation dont
on attend parler d'homme donc ce sont
des mécanismes qui sont assez courants
donc c'est pour ça qu'il y a mon sens il
faut vraiment distinguer ne pas
distinguer l'homme du politique mais
aussi aller encore plus loin en fait
puisque là on est quand même face à des
personnes qui sont à la tête de nos
institutions des personnes qui doivent
faire
de la lutte contre les violences
sexuelles et sexistes un de ces combats
on ne peut pas nier la sincérité de la
plupart de ses membres et pourtant et
bien l'exemplarité n'est pas toujours au
rendez-vous il y a une fracture au sein
de la France insoumise et bien je
parlerai d'une première faille fait
inédit Jean-Luc Mélenchon et isoléal à
tel point que dimanche c'est sous la
pression de personnalité comme
Clémentine ou Manon Brie que le parti a
sorti un communiqué qui contredisait le
position du patron et c'est une brèche
qui s'est ouverte idéologiquement on
peut rappeler qu'au départ l'égalité
homme-femme ça n'est pas forcément le
logiciel de Mélenchon il a été formé
intellectuellement auprès des trots tout
le virilisme et la norme mais sont tweet
où il soutient qu'intin sans parler de
sa femme ce tweet laisse penser qu'il
n'a pas entendu pas compris pas pris en
compte les revendications féministes des
dernières années qui sont au sein même
de la France insoumise pour la première
fois les membres de la fi prennent leur
distance avec lui mélenchon est-il
aujourd'hui le mieux placé pour
représenter les féministes à rebat
certainement pas mal de cartes alors
adrien katnens a quitté son poste de
coordinateur du parti
il s'est mis en retrait de ses activités
parlementaires ce soir il peut rester
député ou pas alors mis en retrait mais
il n'est pas interdit d'hémicycle c'est
ce que disait la députée obono rappelons
qu'il n'est pas mis en examen pas
condamné mais rien n'oblige à laisser
son mandat d'accord mais politiquement
ça va devenir compliqué comment être
dans l'arène politique quand les valeurs
affichées dans l'hémicycle sont autant
en contradiction avec ses attitudes
personnelles vous l'imaginez siéger au
milieu de ses collègues franchement
c'est tout le collectif insoumis qui va
en être en être affaibliologiste Julien
Bayou lui aussi mise en retraite ses
fonctions au Parlement ça c'est une
autre histoire évidemment on ne peut pas
les comparer là on ne parle pas de
violence physique peut-être de violence
psychologique mais une antenne une
enquête interne ELV est en cours après
le signalement de l'ex-compagne du
député on n'a pas beaucoup d'éléments
mais la pression manifestement était
trop forte Julien Baillot se met donc en
retrait et tout ça pose selon moi une
question à partir de quel moment un fait
privé devient un fait politique une
rupture qui se passe mal je ne parle pas
évidemment de violence physique ou
psychologique mais est-ce qu'un est-ce
que c'est pas fait politique est-ce que
ça disqualifie un ou une responsable
politique les écologistes les échos
féministes notamment place souvent
l'intime et le privé dans le champ
politique on suit un Sandrine Rousseau
qui revendiquait le droit d'aller
regarder dans le lit des gens pour
changer les pratiques on voit que tous
les référentiels ont changé ce qui était
de l'intime est aujourd'hui un élément
public pour ceux qui justement se
placent dans le champ public et
politique alors le risque c'est placé la
politique dans l'intime et est-ce que
c'est demain voir Utiliser l'intime pour
faire la politique on en fera peut-être
d'autres débats alors ça m'intéresse
d'avoir votre réaction sur ce débat qui
est complexe pas simple non il est il
est pas simple mais ça me c'est
intéressant parce que c'est c'est
exactement ce qui se passe entre les
refuges comment un homme politique peut
professer
ce qu'il a envie de professer comment
gouverner quand ses propres paroles sont
en contradiction avec ses actes ou avec
son passé et si on revient à un schéma
antique gouverner c'était d'abord ce
gouverner donc je trouve ça pas
absolument sain ce qui se passe
d'autant plus quand il s'agit de
s'approprier cette culture voilà de la
lutte contre les violences
aux autres on se doit être exemples
un petit peu
il ne faut pas par ailleurs et
d'ailleurs ça c'est quelque chose qu'il
faut quand même sur lequel il faut quand
même assister à mon avis c'est que
souvent dans les cas de violences
sexistes et sexuelles au sein des partis
politiques les premières sur lesquels on
tape les premières que l'on interpelle
ce sont les féministes et souvent ce
sont elles aussi qui ont été elles-mêmes
victimes de violence
aujourd'hui
et qui n'a pas manqué de courage avec
vous Vincent Huget votre parti pris
Poutine piégée entre Colombes et faucon
et oui parce qu'en Russie l'état bouton
est à l'image d'ailleurs des trouffions
expédiés de
la peur battant retraite parmi les voix
fustigeant l'agression militaire de
l'Ukraine celle tonitruante de l'icône
de la pop à la bugatcheva un mélange de
chez la russophone et de Céline Dion de
la Taya dimanche 7 rescapée de l'erceau
vietic inoxydable star du showbiz suivi
sur Instagram par 3 millions et demi de
fans a prié le ministère de la Justice
de la Fédération SIXIS ça existe j'ai
vérifié
donc prix de leur ranger parmi les
agents étrangers donc statut réservé aux
traîtres à la mer Patry sort infamant
d'ailleurs infligé l'avant veille à son
époux Maxime gallkin un illustre acteur
chanteur animateur de 27 ans sont cadets
il faut en finir tonne laugacheva avec
cette guerre qui tue nos garçons et
ravale le pays au rang d’état paria une
fausse note évidemment malvenue pour
Vladimir Poutine un sacré quoi pour le
Kremlin en effet voici que la prima
nationale choyé par la nomenclatura
gratifiée du titre d'artiste du peuple
en 91 bienfaitrice 5 ans plus tôt des
nettoyeurs du site nucléaire ravagé de
Tchernobyl voici quelle rue dans les
brancards alors pour autant gare aux
illusions fût-elle lyrique les vocalises
dissonantes d'Allah ne suffiront pas à
ébranler le putinistant en ce début
d'automne le tsar Vladimir semble moins
menacé par le roulement des colombes que
par le huississement rageur si si c'est
comme ça qu'on dit des faux comptes on
en dénombre d'ailleurs pas mal des
faucons sur les rives de la Volga pas
mal de faucons et quelques vrais
Igor girkin un ancien du FSB le KGB
poste soviétique puis du renseignement
militaire il vient de traiter Poutine de
clown girkin l'estime faible tiède il
résolu il flétrit sa mensuétude envers
les sous-hommes Ukrainiens voués à l'en
croire à l'anéantissement les états de
service de ce gaillard est un service
serait plus exact valent le détour lui a
Séville en Bosnie en Tchétchénie est
plutôt deux fois qu'une avant de
ferrailler aux avant-postes de
navelection de la Crimée puis de la
guerre du donbas au point d'occuper un
temps le fauteuil de ministre de la
défense de la pseudo République de
Donetsk mieux ou pire notre pouce au
crime figure parmi les quatre gradés
séparatistes sujets par contumace au
Pays-Bas pour le crash du Boeing de la
Malaisia Airlines ou droyé en 2014 par
un missile des forces prorus 298 morts
si outrancière soit elle ces
imprécations montrent combien l'étoile
de Poutine à Pali et à quel point se
fissure la peur socle de toutes les
dictatures mais elle suggère aussi et là
pas de quoi se réjouir que la preuve
Vladimir pourrait être plus
crépusculaire encore que son règne
en tout cas et si la peur changeait de
quand en Russie on peut on peut
l'espérer comment vous regardez ces
débuts de fissures alors on peut pas
dire du régime mais une partie petite
partie de la société russe comme Vincent
le dit si c'est pour avoir quelqu'un
encore plus dur ce qui était d'ailleurs
ce qu'on prédisait puisque dans
l'entourage de Poutine certains le
trouvaient un petit peu un petit peu mou
alors c'est encore plus inquiétant c'est
vrai qu'on pouvait se réjouir s'il y a
bien une icône de la virilité ces
dernières années c'était Poutine
souvenez-vous des séquences je sens très
pop culture d'ailleurs de Poutine
chassant lourds ou je ne sais quel
animal torse nu donc là c'était une
bonne nouvelle quoi pour les voilà un
renouvellement un peu des images de la
virilité et qu'on soit un peu moins dans
le cliché mais si c'est pour comment
s'appelle-t-il ce monsieur dont vous
nous rappeliez les états de sévices
monsieur grikin
si c'est lui et ce genre de pouvoir on
peut on peut s'inquiéter pour filer la
métaphore du virilisme quand vous
regardez la télévision russe les
émissions de 20h one par exemple vous
avez vraiment l'impression soir après
soir je m'y astreint une prime de risque
devrait mettre d'ailleurs vu vous êtes
vraiment la pression que vous assistez
une réunion de l'Amicale des impuissants
anonymes qui après trois vodka se
vantent de leurs exploits et de leurs
conquête imaginaires deux éléments
importants et préoccupants aujourd'hui
la Douma la chambre basse est rarement
une chambre n'a autant mérité cette
épithète passe du Parlement russe à
durci considérablement les lois
punissant l'arrêt d'édition la désertion
et les pillages bon
et puis aussi il y a eu l'annonce
précipité en panique de cette référendum
d'annexion dans quatre régions donc les
deux républiques fantômes donnaient
déjà et ekerson et c'est à la fois une
escalade mais c'est aussi une fuite en
avant et un arrêt de faiblesse
et indépendamment au-delà de la Russie
je crois qu'il faut vraiment vraiment
être en alerte sur ce qui est en train
de se passer c'est vraiment ce retour du
culte de la force et de l'absence de
nuance Giorgia Meloni elle dit il y a
pas de voix c'est oui ou c'est non et
ensuite chacun est sommet de choisir
notre camp il y a rien de plus terrible
pour les ce qui croit encore à la
démocratie en tout cas sur la Chaîne
Parlementaire merci infiniment les
affranchis à la semaine prochaine
trouvez refuge merci Gallimard c'est un
roman qu'on n'espère pas d'anticipation
merci à vous très belle soirée sur SCP
tout de suite votre soirée documentaire
avec Jean-Pierre Gratien à demain même
[Musique]